[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous lundi 5 février bienvenue
dans de 7,8 journal sur tv 60,18
l'essentiel de l'actualité locale en 26
minutes
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition elle vient d'être inauguré à
guyancourt la maison de santé
pluridisciplinaire de villa roy compte
18 professionnels et médecins
généralistes spécialistes et
paramédicaux un projet attendu de longue
date pour contrer la menace de
désertification médicale qui pèsent sur
la commune
c'est un collectif national résistance à
l'agression publicitaire a pour objectif
de lutter contre les effets négatifs de
la publicité ce week-end l'antenne
saint-quentinoise a mené une opération
contre les écrans numériques
publicitaires elle nous en parlons avec
antonin moulard membres de l'association
enfin c'est une première à thoiry le zoo
organisait samedi un forum emploi près
de 50 analystes était à saisir à
quelques jours du début de la saison en
2018 au parti blinois et puis nous
parlons également de l'ue vs qu
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines qui sait a doté récemment de
référents sécurité
c'est à suivre un référent défense
pardon c'est à suivre dans ce journal
est mais ont rejoint tout de suite
camille lambert camille lambert qui est
à guyancourt bonsoir alors il ya un
nouveau venu aujourd'hui avec l'ami
lambert dans les yvelines c'est la neige
qui est tombée aujourd'hui et les
yvelines d'ailleurs qu'ils sont placés
en vigilance orange neige c'est ça c'est
depuis aujourd'hui
bonsoir grégory ouioui les yvelines sont
placés en vigilance orange depuis ce
matin par météo france ce midi quelques
flocons de neige sont tombés dans les
départements notamment ici à saint
quentin en yvelines comme vous pouvez le
voir derrière moi mais c'est surtout
cette nuit que la vigilance sera plus
importante dans le département pour
cause de neige et verglas à partir de 3
heures du matin des chutes de neige plus
importantes sont attendues demain mardi
6 février toute la journée et elle
devrait tenir au sol dans l'ensemble de
la région
les cumuls finiront par atteindre 5 à 8
cm à saint quentin en yvelines les
équipes se préparent déjà à intervenir
des engins de salage l'agglomération qui
a mis en place un service d'information
gratuits par sms sur son site internet
peps point ski point fr vous pouvez vous
abonner pour recevoir des alertes c'est
gratuit et notamment pour en savoir plus
sur les conditions de circulation
attention sur les routes car les risques
d'accident sont accrus météo france
recommande d'être très prudents en cas
de déplacement tout particulièrement
dans le secteur forestier où des chutes
d'arbres peuvent donner quelques
difficultés en circulation ne touchez en
aucun cas à des fils électriques tombés
au sol
et n'oubliez pas de prévoir un
équipement minimum au cas où vous seriez
bloqués plusieurs heures dans votre
véhicule au bord de la route notamment
couverture et bouteilles d'eau
les températures ne devraient pas
excéder 0 degré merci camille lambert
--à également à nicolas d'andré aux
moyens techniques et je rappelle donc
que le département est placé en
vigilance orange neige verglas et les
yvelines qui sont également toujours en
vigilance orange inondations ce soir la
région ile-de-france va débloquer 1
million d'euros pour les communes
victimes des crues annonce ce matin de
la présidente de la collectivité valérie
pécresse un fonds d'indemnisation auquel
pourrait s'adjoindre d'autres aides
notamment pour traiter la pollution est
de les cluses de méricourt que vous
voyez à l'image de 150 tonnes de déchets
jonchent la scène sur 8000 m² et les
immondices qui pourraient se retrouver
sur les berges du village quand le
barrage rouvrira et 18 professionnels de
santé généralistes spécialistes et
paramédicaux guyancourt a inauguré
vendredi soir sa président sa première
la maison de santé pluridisciplinaire un
lieu attendu par les habitants de la
villa qui souhaitent lutter contre le
problème de la désertification médicale
sujet de patrick jacques de dixmude et
camille lambert espace de rééducation
podologue et kinésithérapeutes 18
professionnels de santé réunis en un
seul lieu
la maison de santé pluridisciplinaire de
guyancourt mille mètres carrés au coeur
du quartier de villeroy
un projet qui devrait permettre de
lutter contre la désertification
médicale à saint quentin en yvelines
une chute démographique des médecins et
deuxièmement est aussi une augmentation
des charges les médecins ce qui fait
qu'ils sont poussés sera se rassembler
il faut qu'ils changent leur
organisation donc c'est une réponse pour
que nos citoyens ou une réponse de leur
médecin plus rapide vous savez qui n'a
pas été confronté à avoir un rendez vous
à trois mois pour un point médecins
spécialistes c'est en effet un mode
d'exercice qui pourrait médecin est
beaucoup plus satisfaisant car il permet
de nombreux échanges et qui pour le
patient facilite également les choses
puisqu'il permet une bien meilleure
coordination du parcours de soin initié
en 2009 cinq années de travail ont été
nécessaires pour créer cette structure
avec l'aide de saint quentin en yvelines
l agence régionale de santé
guyancourt a pu la mettre en service dès
septembre 2017
mais si les premiers mois sont
concluants pour ce professionnel le
combat contre la pénurie de médecins
n'est pas encore gagné on sait bien sûr
que la pénurie elle vient de la
diminution des numerus clausus pendant
20 ans par rattraper avec des maisons de
santé le la pénurie médicale qui
existent il faut numerus clausus a
augmenté depuis 2005 partir de 2020 ça
va aller mieux selon le ministère de la
santé le principal problème est avant
tout la répartition surtout en zone
rurale afin d'attirer les jeunes
professionnels d'autres maisons de ce
type devraient voir le jour dans les
prochaines années notamment à plaisir
stop pub vidéo trois mots que vous avez
peut-être vu ce samedi à la gare sncf de
saint quentin en yvelines et au centre
commercial espace saint quentin est une
opération contre les panneaux
publicitaires qui a été animé par un
collectif c'est résistance à l'agression
publicitaire bon son en bon soir antonin
molard et vous avez un membre de ce
collectif alors ce week-end c'était une
opération à l'échelle nationale déclinée
donc en local sur saint quentin en
yvelines qu'est ce qui a été fait
concrètement par le collectif alors nous
nous sommes soutenus sommes allés nous
sommes partis de la gare de
saint-quentin et nous sommes allés au
centre commercial espace saint quentin
où nous avons
recouvert dix panneaux des écrans
publicitaires qui sont là depuis déjà
bien un an et demi et qui sature
l'attention des passants par des
messages lumineux qui bouge et donc qui
s'impose véritablement au dans l'espace
visuel du centre commercial des messages
qui ne sont pas forcément sollicité et
nous tenions à les dénoncer
comme l'ont fait de nombreuses personnes
près de 150 partout dans les villes de
france et voilà nous demandons une
réglementation en la matière notamment
locales parce qu'il n'y a rien dans les
règlements locaux
aujourd'hui c'est les communes qui fixe
ces règlements en termes de publicité
alors oui il ya un cadre national mais
c'est surtout les communes qui ont une
prérogative à ce niveau là et notamment
il ya de nombreux règlements locaux de
publicité de saint-quentin des villes de
saint quentin qui sont obsolètes qui
n'encadrent pas du tout en fait tous
aucun encadre les les écrans le vidéo et
nous notre crainte c'est que
actuellement il ya une recrudescence de
deux d'écrans vidéo publicitaire partout
dans les espaces publics
jc decaux et clear channel en diffuse de
plus en plus 122 plus en plus et on
voudrait une réglementation qui les
interdisent véritablement alors vous
menez aussi notamment des actions aura
l'occasion d'en reparler tout à leur
compte des pages publicitaires là
c'était particulièrement donc condé les
panneaux publicitaires animés des
panneaux numériques que l'on peut voir
notamment dans les centres commerciaux
oui tout à fait donc nous notre enfin
autre crainte en fait par rapport à ça
c'est véritablement les la
surconsommation qui est diffusée par par
ses écrans publicitaires qui était la
sommation inhabituel qu'il est admiré
par ses panneaux publicitaires
consommation à la fois électrique parce
qu'effectivement un écran publicitaire
génère la consommation de l'équivalent
de deux foyers enfin un seul panneau
deux foyers on parle de d'urgence
climatique
on parle de de climat c'est indécent et
dans ce climat c'est une forme la coop
21 parle de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique c'est indécent
et de voir ces panneaux tout à fait il
n'y a aucune volonté politique à l'heure
actuelle même des élus des villes pour
avancer en ce sens là il ya des
économies d'électricité à flers qui sont
donnés et rien n'est fait et pour eux et
pour le coup là c'est vraiment une
question de volonté politique ni envie
en même temps des panneaux publicitaires
dans des centres commerciaux c'est le
lieu s'y prête finalement pourquoi
pourquoi il ne faudrait pas qu'il y ait
de publicité dans les centres
commerciaux
un centre commercial mon pour moi c'est
un espace agréable où je peux aller
faire mes achats tranquillement en
connaissance de cause et en réflexion
aussi je n'achète pas n'importe quoi et
je serai à tout le monde d'acheter en
conscience de ne pas se laisser berner
par des messages faux fallacieux souvent
trompeurs et les écrans publicitaires
envoie ce type de messages notamment
pour des produits qui n'ont que peu
d'intérêt
ça peut être de la vodka ça peut être du
fast food
bref toute la vitrine de la société de
consommation on qui essayent de nous
refourguer ses produits produits en
masse et beaucoup et très peu important
finalement donc finalement envoyé sur la
forme la publicité qui peut générer une
pollution mais également sur les les
messages qui sont véhiculés sur
l'opération comment at elle été reçue
samedi est ce que c'est ce que c'était
quelque chose de légal que vous avez
fait finalement sur sur ses publicités
oui c'est complètement légal on peut
s'exprimer dans l'espace public
pour nous c'est un espace semi public
car certes il appartient à l'entreprise
de l'espace saint quentin néanmoins s'il
est accessible librement il n'y a pas de
barrière il n'y a pas le droit d'en pas
de droit d'entrée et en d'un point de
vue juridique c'est un espace semi
public donc à ce titre là il peut être
réglementé par par un règlement local de
publicité et donc nous demandons
clairement que ce soit interdit ces
dispositifs qui poussent des
consommations pas responsable les
personnes qui fréquentent ce centre dont
qui sont interdits et donc les
publicités actuelles soit soit retirée
les écrans publicitaires se retirer et
qu'une législation une réglementation à
l'échelle de tout 50 ans soit fait pour
interdire ces écrans publicitaires
mais justement sur saint quentin en
yvelines si on revient sur l'année 2010
est vous avez mené une action notamment
contre des bâches qui était alors
exposée il ya eu des bâches sur le
vélodrome national également sur le
gymnase pierre de coubertin à à montigny
le bretonneux des bâches en général qui
faisait la promotion de la ryder cup là
pourquoi votre collectif est intervenu
pour quoi et jugé nécessaire
on est intervenu en la matière vous
voyez une nounou
non seulement on enregistrait
publicitaire investi des espaces qui ne
sont pas réglementés mais en plus elle a
aussi des espaces qui sont réglementés
et bien souvent les les espaces
publicitaires ne respectent pas la loi
c'est quand même grave sur le vélodrome
jugez qui ça peut être un risque pour
les automobilistes il ya la nationale 10
qui passe juste à côté du vélodrome des
grandes bâches publicitaires qui peut
être un risque pour les automobilistes
qui regardent ces bâches peut-être en
passant c'est ça aussi la crainte en
fait la publicité a pour objectif de
déclencher une pulsion psychologique
chez la personne de façon à créer une
pulsion chez elle en l'occurrence les on
peut pas dire que les automobilistes
soit une cible puisque les
automobilistes sont censés se concentrer
sur leur conduite beaucoup de
neurosciences de nombreuses recherches
montrent qu'il ya clairement une
intention de saturer l'attention des
personnes pour leur faire un peu ce
qu'on veut alors vous et moi on va dire
mais non on n'est pas influencé mais
bien sûr qu'on n'est pas influencée par
une publicité on est influencé par une
multitude de messages qui se répètent
qui sans qu'on en soit totalement
conscient finalement commencé à utiliser
des mots qui sont diffusées par cette
publicité
les images nous devient deviennent
familières c'est un message qui est
assez difficile à faire à faire entendre
parce que du coup l'individu n'est pas
complètement complètement maître de
lui-même et c'est un message des
nécessaires à entendre et c'est pourquoi
nous menons des actions non violentes en
la matière pour faire prendre conscience
au public que c'est un débat important
et on peut retrouver toutes vos actions
sur le site internet
à noter que s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci antonin un moulin d'avoir été avec
nous et je rappelle que les membres de
ce collectif résistance à l'agression
publicitaire et donc pour l'antenne de
saint quentin en yvelines merci d'avoir
été avec nous al'approche du début de la
haute saison le parc zoologique de
thoiry organisait ce week end un forum
de l'emploi une journée de recrutement
d'agents polyvalents pour la
restauration les caisses ou encore le
service d'entretien des postes de
saisonniers occupé à partir du mois de
mars jusqu'à septembre nicolas landry
s'est rendu sur place reportage
et si moi je pleurais
joël si je peux pas tout de suite je
parlerai parfaite
yoann 20 ans est étudiant en licence
d'économie gestion finance
il vient postulé pour un poste en caisse
restauration au zoo de thoiry
comme lui ils étaient plusieurs
étudiants à vouloir trouver un emploi
notamment pour la période estivale
je venu pour trouver un travail pour
l'été quoi pour essayer de travailler un
peu en ce moment je suis au chômage est
donné sur locales et m'ont dit de venir
ici pour chercher quelque chose et je
suis étudiant et ça m'arrange prime une
étude mois déjà de base quand j'étais
petit je voulais faire vétérinaire après
les études étaient trop longues et
et là j'ai vu que bas qu'ils ont beau
chez moi je suis venu comme j'aime bien
tout ce qui est un hymne alliés de sa
zone des jeunes parfois familiers du zoo
la direction propose différents contrats
pour travailler le week-end les vacances
uniquement le dimanche ou en semaine des
postes saisonniers et flexible pour le
service d'entretien la caisse ou la
restauration et la possibilité de
choisir parmi plusieurs candidats le but
de ce forum
c'était de recevoir un maximum de gens
de collecter des cv et de ne pas dire
tout de suite on a besoin de vous la
semaine prochaine mais peut-être dans un
mois même cet été
moi j'espère avoir des étudiants qui
nous disent en juillet où je suis dispo
ça sera bien plus facile pour anticiper
tout au long de l'année l'effectif du
parc est composé de 58 employés durant
la haute saison ils sont près de 90
personnes a travaillé dans le zoo
le zoo de thoiry justement qui compte
depuis à la fin de la semaine dernière
un nouveau venu un nouveau pensionnaire
unesco c'est le nom de ce jeune à
rhinocéros de deux ans arrivé jeudi dans
le parc il est né en ardèche dans le
safari de peaugres l'unesco va prendre
d'abord ses marques dans son box avant
de sortir vous pourrez le rencontrer à
partir du 14 février date de la
réouverture du site touahri a donc de
nouveau trois rhinocéros
ils étaient 2 depuis la mort de vince
700 mars 2017 à tuer pour sa corne par
des braconniers et nouvel invité avec
moi sur ce plateau c'est sébastien
floquet bonsoir soit vous êtes maître de
conférences en chimie l'institut
lavoisier de l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines et vous êtes
également c'est pour ça que vous venez
nous voir non pas référent sécurité
comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure mais
préférons défense de l'université lui vs
qu s'est dotée de trois référents
défense vous mais également jacques de
maya ray et thomas lydman qui sont tous
deux professeurs en sciences politiques
très rapidement on aura l'occasion de
revenir sur vos missions juste après
mais c'est quoi concrètement un référent
défense pour une université
le principal rôle des référents défense
en fait c'est cette ré des liens entre
entre l'université et le monde de la
défense d'une accord façon très générale
et donc ça répond à un protocole
d'accord en fait entre entre ministère
de la défense ministère de l'agriculture
ministre à l'enseignement supérieur mais
sarmentelles 2016 ce phare moutarde au
col d'accord oui qui remonte à 2016 et
donc et donc toutes les universités et
grandes écoles françaises de renom se
sont dotés de référents défense et
pourquoi auto-écoles d'accord est ce que
ça voulait dire que ce lien entre
justement là la jeunesse l'a dit fait la
défense la sécurité nationale est encore
trop flou et des notions qui était floue
peut-être pour les jeunes l'idée c'était
de sensibiliser à l'école et de
l'université aux questions de défense et
de sécurité qui est pas qu'ils aient pas
qui est pas complètement secure en
soyons donc c'est important d'être
sensibilisé les attentes à 2015 dans un
contexte aussi de menaces terroristes
qui a peut-être le protocole d'accord et
moi c'est vrai qu'il a été renouvelée en
dans ces questions là donc c'est quelque
chose d'important que les gens soient
sensibles à ce genre de questions de
défense et sécurité dit renouvelé en
2007 c'est à dire que c'était déjà en
place y avait déjà un protocole d'accord
qui datait de 2007 en fait d'accord qui
était moins qu'ils étaient moins précis
que celui de 2016 et donc donc
et donc voilà donc depuis 2016 donc
toutes les universités et les grandes
écoles doivent être dotées d'un de
référents défense au niveau de
l'université de versailles donc on est
multi sites on est pluridisciplinaire
donc une levée est ce qu a fait le choix
de d'avoir deux de se doter d'un collège
de référents des sens c'est ça il ya des
référents finalement senior vous en
faites partie avec deux autres collègues
il ya également d un collège junior qui
doit voir le jour avec des étudiants
exactement donc donc nous on a fait ce
choix là qui nous semblait plus
judicieux pour pouvoir échanger pour
pouvoir proposer des choses pour est
actif pour proposer des conférences
salons des intervenants dans différentes
unités d'enseignement donc pour
l'instant des trois seigneurs
effectivement donc donc jacques de maya
thomas steen de man donkey son
professeur en sciences politiques moi
même donc maître de conférences en
chimie et puis donc on a une étudiante
en master de management qui va nous
rejoindre
donc je les rencontre est tout à l'heure
qui sera référente junior et qui
réservistes par ailleurs et puis bon les
avants donc ça c'est encore ouvert si on
peut avoir un ou deux étudiants
supplémentaires
évidemment toutes les bonnes volontés
sont les bienvenues et comment ça se
fait que vous êtes devenu vous pardon
référent défense est ce que c'est vous
qui avait proposé peut-être une
candidature on ça c'est pour
l'université vous a sollicité comment ça
se trouve que je suis depuis quelques
années je fais chauffer sied de réserve
à la direction générale de l'armement
très bien donc je suis très sensible aux
questions de défense et donc je demande
donc l'université elle n'était pas dotée
de référents des français et c'est
effectivement donc c'est une proposition
de ma part donc à l'université donc au
président donc à l'époque didier
guillemot et puis alain puis donc qui
ont qui ont adhéré et qui épie qui ont
validé vide à mourir le ce projet de
mise en place de collèges de référents
défense lesquels sont vos différentes
missions là ça se met du coup en place
s'était mis en place tout récemment la
mise en place cette date 2
fin 2010 7 octobre 2010 est donc la
mission c'est évidemment de créer des
liens entre entre défense et universités
et ça se fait par casser c'est ça peut
intervenir donc d'en haut niveau des
enseignements donc les masters qui sont
qui sont très focalisés sur les
questions de défense et de sécurité ça
peut intervenir au niveau de l'unité
d'enseignement libre
donc il y à une lieue libre qui est en
train de se mettre en place sur
l'engagement citoyen au sein de laquelle
donc on va intervenir pour parler de
réserve militaire notamment la garde
nationale ça intervient également donc
pour favoriser l'insertion
professionnelle des jeunes il ya
beaucoup de possibilités d'embauché dans
au sein des armées lors son temps
militaire soit en tant qu' en tant que
civil soit finalement il ya plein de
manières de pouvoir s'engager
donc c'est également créer des liens
entre autres la recherche donc les
laboratoires et la remet donc en
particulier à des gr donc au niveau des
enjeux stratégiques de la recherche
et puis et puis c'est également une
mission c'est de faire connaître la
possibilité d' engagement citoyen au
sein de la réserve militaire en
particulier pour les étudiants leur
faire connaître
donc il ya un certain nombre de mesures
incitatives qui ont été mises en place
pour que les étudiants s'engagent dans
la garde nationale accorde une aide au
permis de conduire une aide aux études
et c'est donc moyennant certaines
conditions évidemment donc notre rôle
c'est de les informer sur ces sur ces
mesures
et puis notre rôle également donc c'est
pour ces étudiants qui serait ce choix
d'engagement citoyen donc c'est cesser
de les orienter de les conseiller les
écoute et d informer mais aussi de faire
reconnaître l'engagement citoyen donc
auprès de l'université
donc dans ce cadre là donc elle c'est
lui
engagement citoyen qui est en train de
se mettre en place donc les et les
étudiants qui s'engagent de façon
importante
alors dans la réserve militaire mais
aussi dans les associations dans l'école
dans les conseils tudiants et c'est donc
peu pourront pourront valoriser ses
engagements sous forme de cts au sein au
travers de ces deux études donc ça c'est
quelque chose qui va se mettre en place
à la rentrée prochaine
dernière chose il nous restait un peu
moins d'une minute pour venir vous
rencontrer est ce qu'il ya des
permanences est ce qu'on prend rendez
vous à dire ça se passe pas de
permanence même on trouve mon mail assez
facilement sur le site de libé end sur
l'université qui s'affiche actuellement
comme commet comme ceux de mes collègues
je pourrais donc a pas de soucis à me
contacter et puis dans la mesure de mes
disponibilités on discute évidemment il
ya aucun souci là-dessus
merci à sébastien fauqué d'avoir été
avec nous merci vous êtes l un des
référents défense de l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines je
rappelle également que vous êtes maître
de conférences en chimie cette même
université et plus précisément à
l'institut lavoisier à versailles le
sport c'était un match à ne pas manquer
pour les passionnés de handball féminin
ici paris affronter ce week-end l'équipe
norvégienne des vipers kristiansand
c'est difficile à dire en coupe d'europe
c'est au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines samedi pour leur
deuxième match organisé par le club
francilien dans la structure l événement
a attiré plus de 4000 spectateurs retour
sur la rencontre avec nicolas landry et
mickaël l'hydro une atmosphère des
grands soirs ce samedi 3 février au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
plus de 4000 spectateurs se sont
rassemblés dans l'enceinte pour assister
au match de coupe d'europe le hf entre
les joueuses d'ici paris les
norvégiennes de christiane c'est
justement ça permet aussi de faire
découvrir aux enfants
bien un match et puis hein
20 les joutes européennes c'est toujours
particulier parmi une cinquantaine de
norvégiens avaient fait le déplacement
pour ce choc européen comptant pour la
5e journée de la phase de groupes
[Musique]
je ne sais pas si on va gagner je pense
que c'est un match difficile je suis un
peu effrayé l'issue de la rencontre
mais j'ai l'espoir qu'on puisse le faire
un espoir récompenser les vipères ce
christiane cents s'impose d'un but dans
les dernières minutes contre les
franciliennes score final 25 à 24 ici
paris menez pour tous le 3 buts à la mi
temps
l'ambiance du vélodrome n'a pas réussi à
empêcher la remonte haddad et
norvégienne et cd maïs avec des joueuses
très expérimentées
une bonne partie des joueuses de paris
par sa sont une équipe de norvège dont
la gardienne
l'arrière gauche la demi centre est
ouais nous a pas beaucoup réussi cette
année mais bon c'est gagner le prochain
match de coupe d'europe
il y avait une super ambiance l'année
dernière nous avions gagné contre brest
ce match là était très serré et nous
avons une nouvelle fois bien joué ici et
peut-être l'année prochaine encore les
joueuses d'ici paris se déplaceront sur
le terrain des russes de la da pour la
6e et dernière journée de phase de
poules de coupe d'europe en cas de
qualification les lionnes pourrait
revenir pour un nouveau match hors pair
au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines dans les
prochaines semaines un mot de
littérature avant de refermer ce journal
raphaëlle bacqué ariane chemin faisait
la promotion de leur ouvrage la
communauté les deux grands reporters du
monde y retrace notamment à l'histoire
de la ville de trappes
vendredi dernier elle rencontrait donc
leurs lecteurs à la maison de l'étudiant
de guyancourt un rendez vous organisé
par la librairie le pavé du canal
mélanie poker a suivi les échanges
pourquoi on a choisi crap que on avait
le souci on a toujours le souci dans nos
livres de raconter un peu l'époque la
maison de l'étudiant a fait le plein
plus de 110 personnes ont fait le
déplacement
face à eux les deux grands reporters du
monde auteur de l'ouvragé la communauté
tout est vrai tout ce qu'on raconte est
vrai on a essayé de raconter cette
histoire sur pratiquement 50 50 années
de façon agréable aussi il faut que ce
soit un ouvrage plaisant à lire mais
rien est romancé rien n'est inventé où
il a reçu beaucoup de courriers beaucoup
de coups de téléphone beaucoup de
messages donc ça c'est toujours très
agréable quand on écrit un livre c'est
mieux que un livre qui tombe dans le
silence ou l'oubli et c'est pour ça
qu'on est très content continue cette
discussion
une discussion animée d'une heure et
demie dans le public des participants à
l'ouvragé d'autres qui s'estiment
oubliés des avis divergents
j'aime
beaucoup les livres ces écrivains et
puis là voilà je viens de lire celui là
et j'avais vraiment envie d'entendre
leur façon de travailler seul et fort
intéressante puisque qui est vécu être a
été vos culs vécue par plusieurs
communes des yvelines et du de france je
suis trappistes depuis plus de cinq ans
un peu plus de 50 ans maintenant je
connais bien trump et ce livre tel que m
scandalise c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire compte tenu de déjà priori qu'il
donne face au succès de cette soirée la
librairie du pavé du canal envisage une
autre rencontre
la communauté est paru le 3 janvier
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal cette
édition vous pouvez la revoir sur notre
site internet et notre application
mobile tv 78 très bonne soirée et
excellente semaine à tous
[Musique]